freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
neuen video und es ist ein sehr
besonderes video kann man auf jeden fall
sagen ich wurde nämlich gefragt volle
lvm der versicherung ein vmware ist dein
vertrauens menschen fragen die gar nicht
so leicht zu beantworten ist weil es
gibt ein paar menschen die so bezeichnen
würde aber ich musste an eine besondere
person denken nämlich an dave dave ist
22 jahre alt ebenfalls youtuber und mein
büro kollege und nicht nur das sondern
auch mein bester freund und uns
verbindet einiges wir haben in den
letzten jahren sehr viel erlebt obwohl
wir uns gar nicht war so unfassbar lange
kennen warum muss ich an ihn denken es
gab wirklich eine phase in meinem in
meinem leben in meiner karriere auch als
youtube wo ich einfach aufhören wollte
beziehungsweise wo ich mir nicht sicher
war mache ich das ganze noch weiter ich
kann nicht sicher sagen dass ihr dieses
video jetzt gerade sehen würde dass
dieser kanal in mir und auch euch so
viel spaß gemacht hätte in den letzten
wochen wenn dave nicht da ich will aber
gar nicht so viel davon vorweg nehmen
weil ich möchte das ganze nochmal mit
euch und dave gemeinsam rekapitulieren
was wir in den letzten jahren erlebt
haben er weiß von nicht genug der vielen
worte lassen wir taten sprechen so ich
werde hier seit drei tagen auf die
folter gespannt und ich weiß auch seit
drei tagen um was es jetzt geht ich bin
nämlich der größte porsche fan und ich
werde jetzt das erste mal porsche fahren
und das ist von max und eric organisiert
und her die auf die folter gespannt das
ist einzige was mich wirklich begeistert
falsch
wir fahren jetzt erst mal in weinsberg
straße 140 in köln forscht sind
einmal einschalten und tag hallo
falsche autohersteller aber genug platz
ist ja also acht langversion wir reisen
du hast ja schon gewusst hat
überraschende ja aber da muss man sich
wie und du wirst auch weiterfahren wir
werden jetzt erstmal ganz gemischt
unserem ziel chauffiert okay und ich
sie am zitter und weil ich wirklich
richtig aus
sie haben mag eine weite strecke bauen
aber ich habe mir vorgenommen dass wir
einfach 15 unsere gemeinsame freund der
typ passiert
welche richtung der zahlen ja wir haben
ihnen ein büro gemeinsam gehabt dass
ersten büros aber ich wüsste nicht was
das mit adressen zu tun haben könnte in
diesem büro haben wir
angefangen gemeinsam unsere ärsche hoch
zufrieden das war zumindest für mich ich
glaube zugleich aber habe wirklich ein
maßgeblicher faktor dafür dass wir da
sind wo wir jetzt heute sind sondern was
gibt es hier kulinarisch in der nähe
doch was wollen dass wir nicht
reingekommen sind ganz genauso mein gott
und heute kommt rein und es macht sogar
explizit für uns auf oahu quasi das
ganze restaurant für uns
wir standen da vorgaben und so darüber
abgefragt dass wir nicht reingekommen
sind weil man natürlich
reagieren mussten sehr gutes restaurant
und heute scheint es so weit zu sein
sehen
hiernach sehr angenehm einen schönen tag
noch völlig verrückt da guck mal hier
genau hier standen wir und als ich
gemerkt dass wir nicht rein kommen sind
wir auf die andere straßenseite
gewechselt macht nichts wir müssen
eigentlich reichen wir müssen rein aber
es war komplett ausgebucht wie die
nächsten wochen oder monate sogar bis zu
unserem fahrer der eingegangen bei uns
einst verrutschen
mittlerweile ist gewöhnt auch von meinem
hotel tests aber man fällt trotzdem doch
immer mit sein kann doch noch ein
bisschen
herzlich danke sagen an das cobas hier
in köln wir sind wirklich haben die
überfallen heute morgen meinte ist das
irgendwie möglich
[Musik]
bleiben länger darf sondern dass wir
natürlich jetzt auch gleich entsprechend
werkstatt erst mal ist das unglaublich
und ich sag dir jetzt auch etwas zu
essen gibt da ich habe mir gedacht ist
so muss gar nicht über kompliziert sein
es gibt das wiener schnitzel wenn wir
genau deswegen sind wir auch hier
hingekommen damals und ich weiß gerade
eben nicht aussprechen weil ich nicht
wusste ob das wirklich der grund warum
wir hingekommen sind aber sehr gut was
ist das interesse wieder abgerückt im
restaurant switch beide sind und hast
einfach das schild auf den montag
das riecht schon sehr sehr gut danke
sein also starten wenn man
frittatensuppe das ist ganz klassische
österreichisch das gesamte menü wie in
der schweiz - natürlich österreichische
sagen dass die gerne ein bisschen
[Musik]
ich habe mir gedacht dass die besonderen
rahmen hierfür zu wollen um auch unsere
freundschaft zu reflektieren und deshalb
habe ich hier eine präsentation
vorbereitet die sehr gut selbst der
christmann danke gut 100 prozent
meine spiele ja natürlich nicht ist ja
sehr gut ist aber sehr sehr gut ja doch
nicht nur das auf den alkoholkranken ja
oh ja ok ja ein wichtiges heben es ist
tatsächlich zeit ein bisschen
überraschend schon drei jahre her dass
wir uns kennen ja länger als gedacht
aber irgendwie auch kürzer als gedacht
weil dort so zu wir haben ungefähr fällt
so viel miteinander gemacht und so viel
erlebt so dass vor ihm gedacht hätte das
ist halt viel länger habe andererseits
auf die kürzung erst mal tauchen bei
einem dreh ja aber warum ich gehe haben
wir schon in new york gemeinsam und das
spricht ja auch das kurze film
grundstein gelegt worden dass wir uns
problem dann halt paar wochen später
schon so gemacht haben und so vertraut
haben oder sie gemeinsam urlaub geflogen
sind dann eine ganz lange zeit von viel
spaß viel unternehmung von vier feiern
von vielen aber andere sache etwas
kürzer kam und neben unserer sowieso
noch so großen freundschaft wollte ich
eine sache noch besonders hervorheben
heute nimmt wie sehr wir uns gegenseitig
einfach geholfen haben und ihr eine
langenfeld projekt viel spaß und wenig
orientierung steht lars lebens bleibt
deshalb war es so passieren lassen wir
brauchen noch vorbeigefahren sind am
heutigen 7 2020 haben wir hier vorne um
die ecke unserem tor und wir auch hier
essen den leuten also ich kann natürlich
für mich selbst sprechen ich habe das
glaub ich im intro schon mal so ich war
ja wirklich nicht sicher ob ich so
weitermachen ob ich es nicht einfach
jeden speicher gut sein also ein
bisschen traditionellen berufsweg
verfolge und ich glaube wirklich so wenn
du nicht gewesen wäre es wirklich
wirklich hätte es vielleicht nicht so
dann würden wir nicht hier sitzen ich
hab mich diesen job ding so unendlich
feiert und ein stück weit zählt das
vielleicht auch wirklich soweit
gegenseitig das hat ja ich habe mir
weiterhin zu erste eigene shaping the
world hat es zu gerade die ersten sachen
gemacht für das projekt das büro in dem
wert sind wo noch alles zustand von
unseren vermietern wenn man sich das
allein anschaut einiges passiert und
jeden fall das beste daran ist das ist
schon unglaublich und es zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt einfach auch so mehr als man
sich überhaupt vorstellen konnte erhalte
man mir vor eineinhalb jahren ohne
verein diesen status kurve zeichner
begeistern kommen aber keine reife aber
das gute ist dann natürlich noch mehr im
geschäft nächstes jahr anfang nächsten
jahres mit ihnen wir gemeinsam natürlich
neues angebot und ich bin sehr sehr
gespannt was wir alles noch gemeinsam
schaffen können
was ich danke ihm einige wunderbare
chance haben
franken wir danken uns wirklich verrückt
weil er gerade durch diese präsentation
erst wieder bewusst geworden ist was in
den letzten jahren passiert ist weil man
in so einem konstanten lauf ist und das
alles an einem vorbeizieht und was man
das wirklich gerne gar nicht mitbekommt
es ist wirklich so somit dir was mit den
ganzen jungs haben aber so seine heimat
natürlich sagen ich bin komplett von
colette flesch alter richtigkeit
danke sehr
wir haben ja einen gurken erdäpfelsalat
dazu ein wiener schnitzel zitrone und
preise wären ganz simpel gehalten aber
ich glaube auch ganz lecker ich bin ich
schon was in der kabine das orchester
man muss auch wirklich einmal festhalten
an einem montag einen chauffeur in einen
für ein geöffnetes restaurant zu fragen
dort drei gänge zu speisen und das auch
noch mit dem besten freund das ist nicht
normal und das ist wirklich zum großen
teil wirklich so lang dieser geschichte
mit dem büro das er jetzt gegenseitig
gepusht haben aber auch so eine
spielerische art und weise das ist ja
einfach hobby zum beruf machen natürlich
kommen auch so sagen wie die partner
kommen von videos dazu noch ein dickes
dankeschön an die fh es ist einfach so
real dass das also überlegen
sonderpreise du kannst du noch mal
bestätigt also ich
wünsche nicht dankbar genug sagen vielen
dank an die helfer
und abseits des ganzen teuer essen gehen
usw es ist wahrscheinlich das beste an
dem heutigen tag zu merken woraus
wirklich ankommt deswegen hat mich eben
auch diese präsentation so gewählt dass
es vielmehr darum geht dass wir
gemeinsam an einem strang ziehen an zwei
verschiedenen projekten und uns dabei so
sehr unterstützen können dass wir also
nicht nur gefühlt ist für den traum
leben es ist völlig aus
[Musik]
danke danke haben ein palatschinken also
quasi empfang kuchen gefüllt mit kanal
rovers aber es ist wunderschön anzusehen
und das eis dazu schmeckt auch sehr sehr
gut so wie diese kurzurlaubs gerade das
ist nicht so dieses ding so wo bin ich
hier ja das ist einfach so ein sehr
aktives genießen weiß halt nicht so
komplex ist mehr weil ich aber sehr weiß
er ich glaube dass das sehr heute ist
auch wieder mehr süß als sonst was aber
auch geil ist also und nicht so ein
happen ein erlebnis sondern einfach auch
noch mal eine richtige mahlzeit nicht
nur dass die cs gut sondern die
überraschung ist auch geglückt ich danke
max vielmals natürlich mehr in worte für
das gute essen für das die
detailverliebtheit in dieser
überraschung das war ein absolutes fest
und ich hätte mir nicht selber besser
danken können nein ich will mich auch
selbst tanken und pascal egger war eine
schöne zeit und wir sehen uns gleich zu
hause das war meine überraschung für
dave meinen vertrauens menschen dem ich
wirklich viel zu verdanken habe und wenn
ein vertrauens menschen mal nicht mehr
helfen kann dann springt die lvm ein und
steht ihr als starker partner zur seite
auch wenn es jetzt keinen porsche
geworden ist ich glaube wir kommen
trotzdem eine große freude machen das
war für uns beide glaube ich sehr
besonders also allein bin ein
abgesperrtes restaurant und dort man
muss das hat irgendwie alles schon
gesehen zwar unfassbar kraft und ich
noch mal herzlich dankeschön an die lvm
supercoole kampagne es ging ihnen auch
einfach darum so dieses vertrauens
gefühl zu vermitteln ich hoffe ich habe
das gut geschafft und herzlichen dank
wir sehen uns beim nächsten video wieder
war es gut bis dahin schafft